erica are you nervous that if you're too
mean to carol baskin in your
thing that she might whack you like it
is crazy
um listen i'm as serious as you are
my darling
derek's back the six-time mirror ball
winner is being added to the panel
len's still a part of the show but
executive producer and host tyra told us
why he won't be on set
because uh he is in england and there's
all these travel restrictions
and stuff because of covet 19. there was
a few too many gimmicks going on
yeah i didn't like this are you going to
be able to be mean derek
right i'm not going to be mean i'm going
to be fair i'll be honest
but i'm definitely not gonna be me
that's just not who i am and here's the
thing
i'm not i'm not like replacing you know
really even he's still very much a part
of the show
yeah do you know what that way is i
don't know yet um
i envision it being digital in some some
fashion some way or hologram
i don't know who knows who knows your
other dance show world of dance
did you have to go to miss jennifer
lopez and ask her permission
it wasn't quite like that you know not
quite like that but um you know for me
um i love world of dance so much you
know that show is so phenomenal and
that's what's so great about the two
shows they're so different
they're so different so it doesn't feel
like i don't feel like that sense of
conflict
you